all right there are the
last 10 super bowl mvps a lot of
quarterbacks with plenty of receivers
you get the periodic
defensive player there's been nine
defensive players who have won super
bowl mvp only
six running backs all time trivia
question for today as we do the
non-quarterback edition
of our super bowl mvp draft chris named
the two players
and there have been two of them who have
won back to back
super bowl mvp awards whoa okay
man there's been historian i know
historian you got me
you got me nervous here i'm i'm actually
really am nervous um
wow there's been two quarterbacks two of
them back to back so
terry bradshaw's won because i know he
won it in 13 and 14. he'd beat the cow
correct
right hold on we got one more did i have
to name both of them or just one oh you
gotta name them both
oh my gosh i know i know this this is
gonna
montana didn't win back-to-back so hold
on give me a second
aikman no holy crap bola
who am i missing i'm guessing tom brady
you're going to be very upset when you
hear it bart stark oh my gosh
i knew it i knew it was something
obvious i knew it
i didn't go back to one and two oh my
gosh
damn i'm all right this is this is not
gonna be easy because
yeah it's non-quarterback you gotta take
the quarterbacks out of the mix
um i'll i'll go with
travis kelsey you know if it's not gonna
be my homes
uh kelsey has a big game you know maybe
my homes has
not tremendous stats but kelsey has one
of those games where he has like 13
catches for 180 yards and uh
and a couple of touchdowns and actually
he's the one other than the quarterbacks
at plus 1000 bet 100 win a thousand
kelsey is the third guy on the list
that's who i'll go with makes sense i
mean like if mahomes has a day where
it's like 290 yards and maybe two
touchdowns and one interception
and kelsey's you know got 180 of those
yards i could see that like him being an
mvp that way
you know a lot like a jerry rice to joe
montana and super bowl 23 or something
like that
i wouldn't be shocked so that's a good
pick by you uh i'll go over to tampa and
their defense here
you know i just think that if there's
gonna be someone other than brady
it'll probably be someone from the
defense because they've done something
to stop one of the greatest offenses
we've seen in the history of football
kind of like what you know von miller
did to cam newton and company
i don't know which guy to go with that's
where i'm like there's uh but i'll go
shaq barrett i'm gonna go shaq
barrett all right a guy that you know
led the nfl and saks in 2019
he did strip sack fumble mahomes the
first time around
and it's going to take something like
that and maybe even another one of those
for them to win the football game so
i'll go shaq barrett
do you remember who the defensive
co-mvps were from super bowl 12 from the
dallas cowboys
historian i do so harvey martin
yes okay and randy white
perfect well done playing once again
thank you very much
uh you should get the next pick for that
although i i did know that one too i
remember that because it was so
it was like it felt wrong to me there
should only be one right okay
uh next one for me
i'll go mike evans i'll go mike evans a
couple of
same same reasoning as travis kelsey no
reason to repeat it all
big yardage couple of touchdowns brady
has an interception or two you know the
julian edelman dynamic it was edelman a
couple of years ago
mike evans same reason this time if the
bucks win
yeah i i hear you're there i mean the
the logic there
certainly makes sense and he
kansas city played man-to-man the first
time around against tampa bay mike
and did a pretty good job rashad
breeland was very good against mike
evans
i would think after that game kansas
city is going to feel good again
about hey we'll leave him one on one
which might not be a good thing
because maybe you know tampa and brady
and everybody got something in store for
that this time so that'll be uh
something to watch for for sure all
right well
hey it's it's super bowl you know and
it's
you know it's two two rockets up your
butt are good but i got a guy that's got
three rockets up his butt and i'm gonna
take him that's right tyree kill welcome
to the mvp conversation
you know just the same reasons you
talked about travis kelsey or anything
we already saw he could be special
against this team he might get some
opportunities
hey got 200 yards in the first quarter
the last time
if the bucks just kept pace a little bit
there early on who knows what he would
have had
so i just can't wait to see what tampa
does to try to change the outcome from
what they did the last time but tyree
kill certainly
on my radar for an mvp here's why i
think that he won't win mvp
i think he's got enough baggage sorry
chiefs fans and i don't like hearing it
but he's got baggage that will keep the
sports writers who are voting on mvp
from voting for him they'll skew toward
mahomes
if hill has the kind of numbers that
would justify i just feel like the human
dynamic
will take over in that moment and they
won't want to see him be the super bowl
mvp and i don't have a vote
i'm not saying that it's don't don't
don't blame me if it doesn't happen but
i could see that happen
i'm gonna go devin white with my last
one i'm surprised when you started
searching for bucks definitely i know
him no he's the heart and soul of that
defense he is and and
uh you know right place right time if he
has another one of those yet again
right place right time moments generates
a couple of turnovers
it'll be just like dexter jackson
remember dexter jackson won it
in 37 for the bucks and if they had
voted just a couple of minutes later it
would have been dwight smith
yeah right my buddy dwight yeah didn't
he had two picks six
two pick sixes in the last like three
minutes of the football game
uh but yes unbelievable that defense
that showing in
hey it's gonna take that kind of
performance i think from the buccaneers
once again if they want to win the super
bowl at least in my opinion there
uh i'm with you mike i mean i wanted to
do the devin white thing too
i just went with the sack thing devin
white is the best player
on the bucks defense there's i i have no
hesitation in saying that and i feel
pretty comfortable
saying other than chris jones he's the
best defensive player in this game other
than chris jones and i'll go with chris
jones as my last one
i could see chris jones having two or
three sacks in a game
you know a tip pass that gets intercept
intercepted
maybe a strict strip sack fumble or
maybe he's the guy that just
f's the play up a whole lot in the run
game and does things like that and gets
a few handful of sacks with it too but
to what you've always said with brady
pressure in his face those issues
chris jones will be a a big part of that
all right bonus question football
historian and one of these is going to
be easy because
we it was just had been on your mind the
other day
three franchises have won super bowls
with three different starting
quarterbacks how many of them
can you name okay well washington
football team right we just we were
talking about that with joe gibbs and
they're just amazing how he did that
how about the green bay packers
bart starr brett favre of aaron rodgers
and how about that old
has been old guy phil sims new york
giants jeff hosteller eli manning
wow boom i was thinking cowboys
no it's only aikman and stalbach it went
to my mind too but i was like wait it
was only they are the only two that won
the super bowl
so starbucks started six morton must
have started five
that's what it was they lost five right
starbucks started six
and 12 and aikman started the other
three right wow
yeah giants sam's hot stetler hey and uh
manny which doesn't belong and why hey
which one which one's had
shaving cream in his shoes hey
i uh just just to let you know historian
just to let you know historian yeah all
right well done
thank you yeah give me this give me the
final score super bowl 39.
oh okay hold on i gotta i gotta think of
what super bowl 39 is real quick that's
the hardest part historian you already
know okay oh man super bowl 39
is eagles uh patriots right because
super bowl
40 oh no well it's mvpd on branch
and the paper that's not what i asked i
know the pr i'm going to say the pay i'm
not going to be good with this one
i'm going to say patriots oh twenty
seven twenty but i'm wrong twenty seven
twenty seven seventeen it wasn't seven
seventeen it might have been what was it
all right they don't hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports